PRESENTER: Welcome to Cloud
Security Basics, a series where
we explain the ins and outs
of securing your application
on Google Cloud.
Sound fun?
Then stick around,
because in this episode,
you'll learn about
why you shouldn't
log into a compromised server
instance during a breach.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[PHONE BUTTONS DIALING]
BRAD ACTOR: Greetings,
cloud detective.
Last episode, you used Google
Cloud's Operations suite
to track down a
compromised employee.
But this time, I have finally
gotten into your system.
I really have.
I repeat, I have
breached your system.
So riddle me this.
What can you do about it
now that I'm on the inside?
Hurry up as fast as you can.
Try to get me out before I
swap all of the employee photos
with cat photos.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
So here's what we know.
Brad Actor says he's
breached my system, which
is a strange thing
for an attacker to do.
And I haven't
received any alerts
from my monitoring system.
Maybe I should log in
and see what I can find.
Actually, no.
That could be playing into
exactly what Brad Actor wants.
I almost just made
a really big mistake
and logged into the
compromised instance.
But many attackers plan
for this exact response
and actually try to steal admin
credentials as they log in
to fix the breach.
So a general rule here
is to avoid logging
into a compromised
server during a breach.
Hmm.
So how can I see if
Brad Actor really
did breach my system without
compromising it further?
Well, luckily, we've
set up an external store
for our security logs
that we can still
check out what happened.
By putting our forensic
artifacts in a separate place--
in this case, a
Google Cloud project--
we can examine the problem
without alerting the attacker.
This lets us better
understand what's happening.
And we can watch and record
their actions to tip off
local authorities if needed.
We set this up by using Google
Cloud Operation Suite's Export
feature in combination
with sinks,
which are basically filtered
exports for log entries.
The supported
destinations for sinks
can be a cloud storage bucket,
a Pub/Sub topic, a BigQuery
table, or a Cloud
Logging bucket.
So we created a sink in our
application program, the one
Brad Actor says he compromised.
And we copied those logs
into a Cloud Logging bucket
in our logs monitoring project.
We ended up using a
Cloud Logging bucket
because unlike logs data
that's stored in Cloud Storage,
logs stored in Cloud Logging
are indexed, optimized,
and delivered to let you
analyze your logs in close
to real time.
Another benefit of
this approach is
that it allows us to
set up a system where
we view all of our
project logs in one place,
simplifying monitoring
everything in our cloud
environment.
Looking through my logs, I don't
see any suspicious activity.
Hmm.
I guess it's best to be patient
and wait this one out and see
if anything does pop up.
Uh-oh, I got it.
Now, that's just devious.
BRAD ACTOR: Drats, detective.
You foiled my plan.
It's true.
I didn't fully
breach your system.
But I was hoping to
steal your credentials
when you attempted to log in.
It would have been a
mistake to immediately log
into the supposedly
compromised server.
But I know you would have
examined your audit logs, which
means you must have set up a
separate security environment
for your forensic files.
Well played, detective.
Well played.
That's all from me for now.
But I will come back more
devious and mischievous
than ever in the near future.
PRESENTER: So there you
have it-- another episode
of Cloud Security Basics.
For more information
about securing your cloud
environment, be
sure to check out
the links in the
description below.
So stay tuned for the rest
of the Cloud Security Basic
series, because when
it comes to security,
you can't let bad actors win.
[MUSIC PLAYING]